- I keep trying to start
and before I get anywhere
it looks like this.
(peppy music)
- You wanna divide your
hair into three even pieces
and then you're just gonna
cross your other strands
over the middle piece.
- I can't even put the hair
in a (bleep) tie knot thing.
- Now my wrist is trapped.
- So I'm gonna go under with that one...
- Even just the grabbing three strands
of hair is vexing me.
- I want a third hand
to hold that third one.
(laughs loudly)
- This is bullshit.
- God, this is hard.
- I think I'm doing it.
I'm doing it, I think.
Does that look good?
- You go one over the middle and hold it.
Two over the...
(groans in frustration)
- Over, pull, hold.
Over, am I losing it?
There it is.
- That just looks like I rolled it up.
God (bleep) damn it.
- How does she do this?
I can't...
- We're gonna do this.
We're gonna get it right.
We're gonna make my hair beautiful.
- Look at this, I am Katniss Everdeen.
(man screams loudly)
- This harder than that damn A.C.T.
- This is so frustrating, I can't do it.
- Easy.
First braid, knocked it outta the park.
- Start off by taking a section of hair
and your gonna...
Like the three strand braid,
you're gonna divide this
into three even pieces.
And you're gonna cross the
right strand over the middle,
and the left strand over the middle.
- And we're gonna separate it
into three even strands.
Which in my case is just whatever
the (bleep) I can get a hold of.
- How is she doing this?
- How do you even grab
just some of your hair?
- Give up.
I wanna cry, this is just too much.
- This is the secret, you braid
it in the front of your head
and then you flip it backwards.
- And then you take it,
and then you cross under the middle.
And then you take it,
and then you say (bleep) it
and you just start (bleep) tying it.
- It's like the hair is
breeding with itself,
and just multiplying.
- French braids are bullshit,
and it's never gonna work.
It's never gonna work.
- I give up. I quit.
I can't do it.
- (bleep) this.
- I understand why women
do lazy up dos now.
Yeah, what if I just do this?
It looks not the worst.
Not good, but not the worst.